Thank You Beth thank you all for coming
just let me know if you have any trouble
hearing me
so as Beth said I'm this is my thesis
proposal and I'm going to be talking
about a study I'm interested in doing in
imatinib resistant CML cases and I'll
talk a bit about the background CML and
resistance about my aims which will
include driver gene identification and
waiting factor pathway analysis and then
some about the potential interpretation
and significance of results that we
might get out of this so chronic
myelogenous leukemia is a dual phase
leukemia which is really famous for its
clear genetic hallmark the BCR Abel
translocation between chromosomes 9 and
22 this is the so-called Philadelphia
chromosome it was first characterized in
1960 and it was really the first example
of a genetic hallmark with serious
disease and in later work showed that
this was the primary driver of CML in
most cases and this transfer or this
translocation codes for a fusion gene
the beasts variable tyrosine kinase and
the way in which this affects the cell
is by unlinking phosphorylation of
downstream pathways which are involved
in differentiation and proliferation of
cells and which is normally a very
tightly regulated process but this
tyrosine kinase essentially spurious lee
phosphorylates these downstream products
leading to unregulated differentiation
of myeloid cells and this shows just a
couple of the pathways that are
activated that are known to
in the BCR Abel pathway the other reason
that this is really famous is the
development of mattnic messily otherwise
known as Gleevec and this was done in
the early 90s in collaboration between
brian ubers lab here in Novartis and
they in this work were able to
successfully create a tyrosine kinase
walking drug and this again was a really
really important result because it was
the first example of a real rational
targeted molecular medicine and really
kicked off sort of in some ways the idea
of precision medicine which has become a
very dominant paradigm in modern
genomics and imatinib acts by blocking
docking of ATP to the kinase domain of
the BCR Abel protein and this prevents
the addition of phosphates to tyrosine
residues in downstream targets these
pathways treatment with imatinib was
really very successful and this is just
a figure showing some of the collected
data from different clinical studies
that looked at the effectiveness of
treatment within that dem and you can
see as much as 80% of cases showed
complete Saito genic response after 18
months which is a really excellent
response to the drug
unfortunately the this is primarily in
chronic phase cases there are two phases
to the disease the first one the chronic
phase is characterized by a
proliferation of myeloid progenitor
cells and this is largely different by
the BCR Abel fusion gene but the second
step of the disease is progression into
full-blown blast prices in which these
progenitor cells differentiate and cause
accumulation of granulocytes in the
bloodstream and peripheral or in the
peripheral blood stream in bone marrow
and really kicks off full-blown leukemia
and that process is a little less well
understood at this point and so the
takeaway is just that while it was very
successful there are a significant
number of cases which progress to the
later stages of disease and imatinib has
not been as successful in treatment of
those and their treatment options are
fairly poor additionally there are a
number of cases a pretty significant
proportion that acquire resistance to
the drug over time and because it's
really a lifelong condition it's
something that is not cured per se
the proportion of affected patients who
acquire resistance over time increases
and becomes fairly significant in
looking at the mechanism by which this
resistance arises a large proportion or
flee 50% or so cases exhibit a some form
of mutation within the bcr-abl fusion
gene and this offer is a really fairly
clear understandable mechanism by which
resistance arises and this is just a
ribbon structure of the BCR Abel protein
in green and the maddening molecules
outlined in blue and you can see it acts
by very very precisely docking into the
binding domain of the kinase and
blocking the action of blocking the
downstream phosphorylation that drives
the disease and most of the cases that
exhibit point mutations have mutations
within that region and this causes a
change in the steric conformation of the
protein thereby disrupting the action of
the drug and so this is fairly
understood unfortunately though roughly
50% of the cases of imatinib resistance
in CML the mechanism is not clear they
don't exhibit clear
mutations to the actual beasts are able
fusion gene and so how this is occurring
is still not well understood and I'm
gonna just highlight a few things that
have been implicated in the literature
just to illustrate the various ways in
which this could be occurring so this is
just a basic schematic of the cell with
variable gene and some of the downstream
pathways that it affects one of the ways
that has been one of the things that's
been discussed is mutations which may be
affecting the bioavailability from that
man and these are been a few transporter
genes that have been noted as being
mutated at somewhat higher rates within
patients who acquire imatinib resistance
and these may be affecting the rate at
which imatinib is brought into the cell
or cleared and the important thing from
this is just that this isn't really in
any way perturbing the disease pathway
itself it's affecting something in the
cell which is acting to block the action
of the drug another example recent study
here identified through an RNAi
screening experiment it's Ellen's
certain genes which when knocked down
led to resistance to Amanda and what
they found was that the knockdown of
these genes led to activation of c-raf
pathway and this acted on one of the
downstream pathways known to be involved
as a downstream product of either the
piece variable gene and so this acts
sort of as a secondary entry point to
that pathway even though the action of
the BCR Abel fusion gene is still being
blocked third one is just an observation
that's been seen where a significant
portion of patients who progress the
blast crisis and have
resistance to mattad have shown a
structural rearrangement where they lose
one of the arms of chromosome 17 which
contains the p53 gene and it's thought
that this might be acting is just a
different sort of oncogenic trigger and
so in this way a different pathway which
could recapitulate the phenotype may be
acting and the point of talking about
these is just that I mean what we're
really interested in understanding is
resistance and so I think you have to
broaden the perspective to the context
of what's going on and so beyond just
the disease pathway itself and there are
multiple ways in which this could be
perturbed being able to effectively
identify what that might be is is a
little challenging I think a central
question that comes up as a result of
this is trying to understand if between
resisting cases that exhibit mutations
the BCR Abel gene and those that don't
whether or not they're activating the
same pathways and whether that means
that there is some alternative mutation
that's reactivating it or it's something
else entirely going on in the cell so my
specific games I'm going to be trying to
do a few types of analyses to look at
two separate things one is identifying
potential driver genes that are specific
to this group of resistant CML cases the
other is looking at the pathway
signatures and I'll be working with the
working with the night Mattox group on a
project with dr. Drew's lab where
they've collected a large number of
samples from patients who have acquired
a maddening resistance both in both
those that have they have mutations
within that gene and those that don't
this is just a workflow of what I'll be
doing we have both DNA seek data the
form of whole exome sequencing and
expression data in the form of RNA seek
and we'll be doing genotyping and
differential expression analysis but all
of those things will be I'll be doing
some of it but it will be in conjunction
with the knight who has the knight group
who have worked out very nice protocols
for the best way to do this so that's
something that will not be quite as
interesting to my stay is something I'll
be doing with them but the real meat of
what I'm going to look at are
identification of these driver genes
using the results of our genotyping and
some of the results of the expression
data and then pathway signatures really
trying to leverage this expression data
and I'll be using a couple of different
algorithms which I will go into more
detail one of the interesting
observations to come out of genomic
studies of cancer in recent years is the
fact that high-frequency mutations at
the gene level are somewhat rare more
often a large number of genes are
disturbed at a lower frequency but when
evaluated as gene sets oftentimes this
problem can be overcome and it may make
more sense biologically to think of them
as networks or groups of genes acting
together within the disease and so I'm
going to be using two different
techniques that attempt to characterize
sets of genes to identify drivers of the
disease but in different ways the first
one is hot 2 algorithm and I'll talk
about just roughly how this works so
starting with a list of
variants that we've gotten from our
genotyping in mapping those variants to
their respective genes we would give
each of the genes score and in this case
they swiftly based upon the frequency
that the mutations are seen across the
collection of patients and then using
this vector of inputs of mutated genes
and then the frequency at which they're
seen we can overlay that onto protein
interaction networks and what this does
is introduce sort of a topological
element to it I mean it really brings in
information prior information that's
known about how these the protein
products of these genes are functionally
related once that's done you're left
with a network of genes or a network
where the nodes represent genes some of
which have scores based on their
mutational frequency and the edges
represent interactions within this
protein network with that the hotnet
algorithm essentially acts by taking the
heat score of each of these genes and
then for each iteration sharing a
percentage of it with all of its direct
neighbors and then as that repeats you
would take the heat going from one node
out to it's related partners would be
spread out to the secondary partners and
what this essentially does is allows us
to identify groups of proteins or
networks of genes that are functionally
related that have physical interaction
in the cell or punitive interactions in
the cell which are mutated across our
samples in our study and once you've
done this you can pull out significant
networks which may be presented of
groups of genes that are acting together
in the disease
something I'm also interested in trying
out thinking about is our various
metrics for the gene scores one other
idea I have is T views
differential expression between the two
groups those with the VC are able
independent phenotype and those with the
dependent phenotype and look at the
differential expression for those
mutated genes as a potential score and I
think that would be interesting to
compare that to you because it's really
II looking at mutations versus in some
ways the expression it could be
different in a way that's meaningful
the second method that I'll be using for
identification of driver genes is based
on this idea of mutual exclusivity and
this is based on the idea of as tumors
evolve new cells arise with new
mutations and if those mutations disrupt
some biological function or pathway
which leads to further differentiation
this can be thought of is conveying a
selective advantage in a Darwinian sense
and allows them to proliferate at a
faster rate than other cell populations
and the idea of mutual exclusivity given
that is that there are these sets of
genes which exhibit a pattern where
usually one and only one of the gene
members is mutated in any given sample
and there have been a couple of studies
that have shown that well within cancers
that these sets of genes are members of
distinct disease pathways that are known
to be part of a singular pathway
structure and so one of the hypotheses
that's attempted to explain what this
pattern might represent is that these
might be identifying sets of genes which
are acting
that are members of the same pathway and
so knocking essentially mutating one
would cause this increase in Fitness in
the context of cancer but past that
point mutation of another another
partner or downstream partner would have
very little effect in increasing its
proliferation and so I think I think
it's an interesting interesting
complement to the other method in that
this is identifying sets of genes that
possibly represent membership in the
same pathway as opposed to networks of
genes which are potentially acting in
the context of the disease but are not
pathway members and this is just a
schematic showing the basic idea if you
have a number of samples from different
patients and you look at the mutation of
all your various genes these methods
identify sets of genes marked in red
here where if evaluated on their own one
single mutation is found for each gene
or for just one member of each gene set
across the samples and that's the basic
idea this is a really simple point
example obviously and there are a couple
of algorithms out there that have
attempted to identify gene sets this way
I decided to use one multi dendrix and
there are a few reasons it's not
rigorously tied to any sort of prior
information so it's identifying them and
it truly de novo fashion and it's able
to identify multiple sets of genes
exhibiting this pattern simultaneously
so for him to really interested in doing
something that's able to give a more
more of a context of the expression of
these genes rather than looking at just
the mutational landscape
I think the drivers gene sets are very
useful but it's it's a fairly flat
picture of what's going on in the
diseased state I think having something
that really leverages expression data to
give a fuller picture of pathway
activation is really useful and many of
the more commonly used approaches for
pathway analysis like gene set
enrichment analysis look at some measure
of expression like differential
expression and then test for enrichment
of those differentially expressed genes
within certain predefined pathways and
there's some downsides to that though
its methodology that has been well valid
at this point one is that they generally
evaluate pathways individually which can
present a skewed picture of pathway
activation cuz of crosstalk between
pathways and I'll talk a little more
about this that in a minute but the main
thing is that they're pretty tightly
constrained by our prior knowledge about
pathway membership and waiting factor
analysis is another technique that has
been used in a few papers for this sort
of pathway analysis that offers a less
constrained way of looking at it and I'm
interested in trying this out in the
latent factor model we attempt to
explain the correlation between all the
nor known variables which would be
represented by the genes we're studying
in these expression datasets in terms of
a smaller number of unknown variables or
latent factors which could represent
kampf compound
groups of genes and in that way it acts
sort of as a gene or sorry a data
reduction technique and I'll just make a
few points about how this works and
basically what you have as a result of
your experiment is this matrix of
expression values I'm shown by the
response matrix here where you have a
number of samples and you have some sort
of expression output for each of the
genes and the weighting factor analysis
models this as a linear combination only
a product of the pathway signatures for
those genes and the sort of true ground
state of pathway activation in your
sample which is really what we're
interested and we don't know it's doing
this it's able to extrapolate the pull
out the pathway activation that's
causing the pattern of expression that
we're seeing and the factor analysis has
its own set of issues interpretive
ability of the latent factors can be
difficult so you can sometimes combine a
number of genes that don't have a little
obvious common functional context
pathway crosstalk is a real issue and
this is a product of the fact that
pathways are really oftentimes
hierarchical they one pathway can be a
subset of a larger pathway many pathways
share gene members so if you're doing a
pathway analysis you really want to
understand what is driving your disease
you may have one or two pathways which
are driving it but are also affecting
other pathways with which they share
genes and so in terms of interpreting
what you get out of it this is an issue
you have to take into account and then
just the you
the type of data that you can use as
inputs some of the methods that are out
there there's not too many but a few of
them use just simple gene set lists as
you get from kegg pathway database or
they might use actual differential
expression or magnitude of expression
values all of which give a little more
detailed view of what's going on and I'm
proposing to use a fairly recent model
the sine of the Johnson lab and Boston
University and the important thing here
is just that it's a fairly flexible
version of this lake factor analysis
framework that allows or that accounts
for a few of these issues that I brought
up and it it allows the evaluation of
paths of multiple pathways
simultaneously and they've shown that it
does a good job of avoiding pathway
crosstalk and it also allows or a
variety of different inputs as pathways
in its pathway signatures either gene
sets or actual magnitude expression
values
and I think comparing the results of
these two to aims could be potentially
pretty interesting I think that looking
at the driver potential driver genes
that are identified using these methods
and looking at how they looking at their
membership in pathways that are
identified between the two groups of CML
patients could give us some clue as to
what's going on if they're if they're
present in pathways which are not
differentially expressed between the two
groups that could be indicative of
reactivation of the same pathways seen
in a normal each variable driven CML I
think if they're if they're enriched
within pathways that are unique to the
that are differentially expressed
between the two groups and unique to the
variable independent group that could
indicate a different mechanism is being
used I think it could be interesting I
think it would be interesting and add
some context to be able to understand
what this means and another thing is
that I'll be focusing most of my
analysis on chronic phase patients
because I think it makes the most sense
clinically in that blocking the
transition from chronic phase to the
last crisis phase is really how imatinib
is able to successfully treat the
disease and I think something that is
identified in that phase is more likely
to be meaningful in terms of secondary
treatments that might have some effect
on preventing resistance in these cases
but we have a handful of Kate of samples
that are from newly diagnosed patients
who are on a matinee treatment but have
not acquired resistance and so I think
looking at some of the driver genes and
pathways signatures that we find in
those samples to see if they're present
early on and whether they potentially
could be predictive in any sense is
something that can be interesting as
well and then as far as the significance
I think it would be very useful in
understanding potential targets for
secondary therapies I think it also
could this resistance could be acting
through similar mechanisms as the as
what is seen in normal CML in
transitioning from the chronic to blast
phase and I think it could be
interesting in the context of that and I
think it also could be interesting in
understanding the mechanism of a typical
CML which doesn't exhibit a canonical
beast variable fusion gene and in
conclusion I just want to thank my
committee i advisor Beth and Christina
and Shannon for all your valuable
feedback and my family we've put a lot
of stress and neglect over the last two
years a lot of them in school thank you
so when you're for the first hotnet
method you've identified jeans and put
in can you describe the hot/cold scale
that you plan to apply to those jeans
and the criteria that you want to
identify as as being hot or cold yeah
well I mean I think as I said the most
basic metric for that that's used in
this is just the frequency that they're
seeing across the samples and so a
larger value or hotter score for each
gene would be for those obviously that
have a high frequency of mutation do you
think that you'd actually see it would
those be the ones that you would believe
would be more you wouldn't went through
the sort of long-tailed cancer and that
most of them are not frequently
recurrent mutations do you think that
that you should that the hot ones should
be the most highly recurrent necessarily
or I think so I mean it's still I think
operating under the idea that the
mutational frequency even though they're
not at seeing a high frequency that that
is indicative of their significance in
the disease I think the thing that
really lets you get round is the
structure of the protein interaction
Network and that's what's really
identifying the networks of genes the
scores do sort of reinforce that and
allow you I think to pick out more
easily important networks and reinforce
the increase the I guess the heat
signature of those networks that have
both a lot of connections and a
significant amount of mutation within
their group but I think the thing that's
really identifying them is the protein
interaction structure that's your
question
I keep taking it yeah I just would like
to add to the discussion about that
because I know we talk about this a lot
and the the difference between an
individual personalized medicine
approach for which we do we've developed
algorithms to look at an individual
person but also in the population
context across samples so we look for
yes mutations that are in more than one
but we don't want to get to the point of
polymorphisms in the population so we
don't want to get too high so there's
that balance between more than a few and
not too many but also one of the things
that has to be carefully thought about
in this whole project and projects like
this is the inputs of the the variants
that we actually input in and how we
screen those out from all the WS so
there are several ways that we do that
but that's one really important aspect
of determining which ones which
mutations we would actually even want to
use as inputs which so if I'm
understanding right you're using the
mutation data with hotnet to Bill to
kind of find some genes their targets
are and all in an expression data with
more matrix factorization type idea and
I'm wondering about using using the heat
from the mutation data but instead of
protein-protein interaction networks
applying that to your latent pathways
that you discover from the other one if
you could combine those together I mean
I thought about that early on when I
always working on my thesis proposal I
think you have to be careful to not to
not sort of double back on yourself and
you know in identifying groups of genes
that are mutated with a certain
frequency and then these like driver
genes
and then using those as your pathway
signatures you're drawing from the same
data set that you're analyzing and I
think in the I think in the factor
analysis having predefined pathway
signatures that are are outside of your
data set is an important aspect of it
and so I think I was a little worried
about the possibility of it being a bit
circular but I think about a little bit
more but I was thinking more because the
mutation and expression yeah they're
different types of did I mean they're
the same yeah yeah it's something I'd be
interested in investigating I mean I
really I would like I'm really
interested in methods that can in some
way integrate these different types of
data in a meaningful way and it would be
really nice if there was a way to do
that but I'm not exactly sure at this
point
how that would happen Ted do you have
any thoughts about how you're going to
present your final results to
researchers um I mean I think
I mean I think I think with this sort of
study there's there's no way getting
around trying to work with a lab after
identifying some of these in order to
see if there's a way we can validate or
do some more experimental work to look
at whether this is something real and
this is the I think the downside to some
of these I guess machine learning
approaches in some ways is that it's
hard to know whether what you're seeing
is real at all times and we we do have
we do have known BCR Abel driven
pathways that could act is some sort of
validation to understand to see whether
like what I'm getting out of this makes
any sense see if some of those things
are included but I think that you know
we mean you know coming up with like a
list of potential things and seeing how
that agrees with some of the other
literature that's out there and talking
with the lab about possibly finding a
way to test that
do you think that there's a finite
number of pathways that would be
activated in the BCR Abel independent
mechanism I'm just thinking that you
know if it's still CML there's gonna be
CML pathways that are activated to
maintain that phantom it's not
transitioning to ml or transition to
some other type of disease so you're
really looking at some finite number of
pathways that are gonna still be
activated to produce that type of
disease so is there a way that you can
kind of start to cull that down a little
bit so that you've hone in on some of
those pathways I'm not entirely sure to
be honest I mean that's a really good
really good point I mean I think that in
thinking about this I'm not sure whether
I mean my understanding cancer biology
admittedly is in an early stage so I
guess I don't have a lot of experience
to draw on with this but I didn't spend
some time thinking about whether you
know this is it makes sense that you
would see a number of different pathways
causing this same the same phenotype or
if it would be likely to be just a
couple and I'm not sure not sure exactly
how that party fat is taken into
consideration and getting the choice of
the input pathways for the assign
algorithm other inputs are always yeah I
mean I think for the the pathway
signature inputs I'm hoping to use a
couple of different pathways signature
datasets that kind of are at different
levels of contextual application some
more general ones and then there are
some day sets they're more specific to
cancer and more specific potentially to
leukemias and see if I think you know
looking at multiple data sets that are
sort of narrowing down maybe that would
be a way to
filter some of that out I'm not sure do
you know again based on the way your
aims are set up there you're profiling
driver genes being mutated as per the
detection of variants yeah whole exome
sequencing in the event that for example
there's a newly acquired cryptic trans
location or something whatever new
fusion in the resistant sample that is
the principle responsible reason for the
resistance and thus something that
wouldn't be detected in the setting of
whole exome sequencing but in the
setting of RNA seek would is there a way
to incorporate any of potentially
interesting driver genes or fusions from
the RNA seek data into the level of the
analysis and the driver gene Network I
think both of the driver gene methods
allow for input of multiple types of
mutational data
I think we're I'm like plan is to focus
on the on the single nucleotide variants
because we have a more robust protocol
for determining those in this sort of a
case where we don't have we don't have
normal controls because we have to do a
little more to try and pick out what we
would consider actual somatic variants
and the there are methods for
identifying you know a copy number
changes or structural rearrangements but
without matched data they're a little
less less less certain and so they're I
mean those things can definitely be
incorporated into both of those methods
I think but it would be more issue of
having confidence in those calls
thank you
you